hey everyone you're watching us watch
calm and we are here at PAX West we just
played a bunch of Indies I'm a luxury
career this is scott Butterworth now I
played a bunch you played a bunch but
what was your favorite indie game here
one game if I had to pick I'm really
excited about night in the woods this
game has been in development for like
going on honestly three years actually
they've you back in 2014 and it's
finally due out later this year it's an
exploration based adventure game it's
more narrative driven than mechanic
driven but there is sort of a world
you're in this town called possible city
basically you're playing like a college
dropout who comes back to her hometown
it hopes to find things the way they
were but of course everything's kind of
changed and so yeah exactly and that's
totally my kind of thing like it reminds
you of all the kind of graphic novels
that I love like i'm a big scott pilgrim
fan or like I love blankets and it's
totally my kind of thing so like he's
weird sad coming-of-age stories they're
always appealed to me for whatever
reason in night of the woods in addition
to having a really interesting art style
and really charming anthropomorphic
animal characters definitely has that
kind of tone that sort of melancholy
post-college ennui that whatever is
really appeals to me so nice excited to
see how that he when she plays out when
it finally releases later this year and
where can they find it it's in the pecs
that is one of the packs end game so its
up if your ad packs that is up on the
top floor part of the packs 10 like that
elite group 10 games so now part of the
indie mega booth but still is playable
here on the on the floor somewhere it
packs Daniel yes Alexis we played a game
together we did it really fun it was
super fun remember when people saying
like oh man no one's guys great but I
wish I could play my buddies go play
Astra near it's good fun yeah it's
basically a game when you drop down on a
planet and you harvest things and you
crap things you know stop me if you've
heard this right after this before but
it was so like tell me about it just
felt really good then I mean just be
honest like it sounds really bad but
like for somebody who's played as much
to ask ivan past couple weeks I'm kind
of sick of shooting at minerals and
having them disappear and this one
there's this like super fun like eroding
mechanic where you basically just like
collect resources by like burrowing into
the world and then adding back to the
world it's like you're just able to use
this terraforming going to do what we
want there's like three main elements
that like basically in this bird build
anyway make everything from batteries
two seats that you put together on to
use into your like ramshackle little
little air
after you ramshackle little Jeep and of
course week and of course you got to
play together yeah which is great so I
got to watch you this society sauce
suffocating because of oxygen
deprivation because you went too far and
then at the end we ended up like
building a spaceship and just shooting
into the sky and finding another moon
and going there who's good yeah it was
fun at the game just looks great right
really colorful palette I'm like an
interesting crafting loop where you know
you're trying to like you the thing that
you need to get is further away so you
have to build the thing to get further
away I really enjoyed it it's been
floating around taxes for a while now I
know Mary had it the war remedy three
last year for gamespot earlier this year
apparently it's coming out maybe
sometime this year I hope so yeah it's
really fun John Luke purveyor of fine
videogame videos at your spot suck on
this is your first text friend yes it is
what did you play I played a game called
y2k a postmodern RPG okay I would
describe it as earthbound meets persona
4 meets just the 90s the premise is
you're playing this character named Alex
who in the past has a traumatic
experience with this character named
Sammy who mysteriously just screwed an
elevator and it became just like urban
legend and you get this phone call from
a friend who says hey people have seen
her ghost in this cave and we need to go
check it out and then you go to the cave
and it becomes like a dungeon crawler at
that point a lot of exploration fighting
monsters the combat it's very
traditional turn-based combat mixed with
paper mario like they'll do a little
mini game I thought the game was
fantastic so it's really funny it's
really well written if you're someone
who likes reading lots of dialogue and
just checking out everything I think I
love the game and this is the mega yes
it is in the megabill
and I believe they said they're shooting
for this fall who very night okay be
told you our favorite games at PAX so
far Alexa what is yours so my favorite
game was predictably a JRPG s game
called secrets legend yes and it's
basically like the first legend of zelda
game with except it's three date with a
tiny adorable fox and you're running
around this very beautiful world and
you're killing little slime monsters
that are also really cute they can do
like two hits kill you but they're still
so cute you open treasure boxes you go
into these temples the whole thing is
written in a different language so you
can't actually read any of the tutorial
words you can't read the names of labels
of the items you pick up cuz it's all
written in a different language some
kind of rooms and the lighting in that
game I yes I can't get over the lighting
familiar look like games like Zelda like
an isometric sort of like a phase sort
of element to it as well Everett like
super eye-catching right it's very
beautiful but what shocks me the most
about this is it's made by one guy right
in Nova Scotia yeah swing by turning
away up in the great white north babies
video dr. Fox game it's absolutely
beautiful so you're out tax it's at the
Indy mega booth yes those are our four
favorite games attacks if your ad packs
and don't play them also go pay all the
other great games and if you're not
attacks stay tuned to get back on for
more coverage Oh pax pax Pakistan I love
it
I